So here we are, together.
But we're in a technological trance.
Here we are together,
but we're divided by tribalism.
but we're distracted by mass myths.
We've been separated by walls,
windows, computer screens, borders.
But we're united in our hearts.
Oh, we've argued
and quarreled in the past.
But now we know we've got a common bond.
Humanity.
So why are we all here?
Maybe we're all looking for a key.
A key to unlock this political, economic,
social, cultural paralysis.
Maybe the answer
is in a little word: empathy.
Empathy is not just walking in someone's
shoes or feeling someone's pain.
Empathy is the secret ingredient
for finding a human connection.
So I want you to open up your hearts
and open up your minds,
because in times of confusion,
we must not lose our capacity
to dare to be kind to each other.
Some years ago,
I had the great privilege
to be invited to the White House
to do this.
Now this has got nothing
to do with politics.
This is a cultural moment
in American history.
This is Michelle Obama's
first portrait as First Lady.
(Applause)
So on this day, I was nervous.
And when I'm nervous,
I get socially clumsy.
Know what I mean?
(Laughter)
So I picked up my camera,
focused on her eyelash,
and in my clumsiness I shouted out,
"Right, my love, I want your soul.
Give it to me."
(Laughter)
Silence in the room.
I'm sure the hairdresser
almost dropped the hairspray in shock.
And as I took this picture,
this devastating look came over her face.
The eyebrow raises as if to say,
"How dare you?
But I quite like it at the same time."
(Laughter)
So then I realize what I just said.
And I said, "My goodness me,
I'm an Englishman.
And in England we invented being polite.
I think Canadians and Americans do it
better now, but we invented it.
And here I am in the White House,
calling you ‘my love’
and demanding your soul.
Please forgive my atrocities."
She stands up, gives me a hug
and whispers in my ear,
"Platon, when all is said and done,
I'm just Michelle."
This is Pussy Riot.
You probably know them as the hardcore
feminist punk rock group
who spoke truth to power
against Putin's excessive nationalism.
And consequently,
they were sent to a Siberian
prison for two years.
But what happens if we remove
those colorful, aggressive masks?
You see something different.
This is Nadia and Masha
photographed after
they were released from prison.
Look at their faces, you can see
the vulnerability on their faces.
You can see that they've
paid a heavy price
for their support of LGBTQ rights
and women's rights in Russia.
Now during their trial
in the courtroom, before jail,
they were kept in a big cage
as if they're wild animals.
Nadia, the woman with dark hair,
the co-founder of Pussy Riot,
she was constantly scribbling handwritten
notes on a scrappy piece of paper.
Eventually, the judge said to her,
"I want you to stand up
and make your closing statement
before I sentence you."
I'm sure Nadia must have known
she's about to go to jail.
Nevertheless, she stood up.
Nervously clutching her piece of paper,
took a deep breath
and read out from her notes.
And what she said to the judge
and to the world, I believe,
will go down as one
of our generation's greatest speeches.
She said,
"I wouldn't give people labels.
There are no winners or losers here,
injured parties or accused.
We just need to make contact,
to establish a dialogue
and a joint search for truth,
to seek wisdom together,
to be philosophers together,
rather than stigmatizing
and labeling people.
That is one of the worst things
people could do."
I believe Nadia thinks
one of the worst things we could do
is to judge each other.
Maybe we need to be less judgmental
and more curious.
When you look at one of my pictures,
you might find yourself making
judgments about that person.
So what happens if I strip away
your capacity to make those judgments?
I take away 95 percent of the picture,
and I leave you with just five percent
that you can't recognize.
But maybe it's the most important part.
The window to someone's character.
The eye.
Whose eye is this?
Always watching us.
Is it someone you love?
Is it someone you hate?
It belongs to this man.
This man.
At this moment,
I would like to pay tribute
to all the courageous, brave,
resilient heroes
who fight against oppression,
who fight for human rights,
dignity, freedom and justice
around the world.
Let's give them a round of applause.
Come on.
(Applause)
So I was driven
through the streets of Moscow,
past the gates of the Kremlin,
and we continued out
of the streets of Moscow
into a dark, bleak, Gothic forest.
We arrived at one of the most sinister
buildings I've ever seen in my life.
His private residence, his private dacha.
And it was surrounded
by a two-story high security wall
with snipers all the way along the top.
As I get out of the limo,
I'm escorted into
the building at gunpoint.
I'm led into a room.
I waited, and he comes in
with a giant entourage.
And I said, "Mr. President,
before I capture this moment
of history on film,
I've got a question I'd like to ask you."
I said, "I was brought up
by my mom and dad
listening to the music of The Beatles.
I want to know if you
ever listened to The Beatles.”
His two translators whisper in his ear.
There's some confusing looks
amongst the entourage,
and then his mood drops.
And in Russian, he orders
the two translators
and all his political advisers
out of the room, immediately.
The bodyguards stay.
And then Putin turns to me
and in perfect English, he says,
“I love The Beatles.”
(Laughter)
I said, "I didn't know you spoke English."
He said, "I speak perfect English."
I said, "In that case,
who's your favorite Beatle?"
He said, "Paul."
I said, "What's your favorite song?
Is it 'Back in the USSR?'"
(Laughter)
Yeah, he didn't like that very much.
And then he said, "No.
My favorite song is ‘Yesterday.’
Think about it."
And I thought about it.
And I realized I'm being sent
a subliminal message
about the old days of power
and authority of the Soviet Union
through a Paul McCartney song.
Now, that human connection
I had with him allowed me in,
and I ended up about an inch and a half
away from his nose as I took this picture.
I could feel his cold breath on my hand
as I focused the lens,
and that's how I got the truth.
The truth is that this is the cold face
of power and authority in Russia.
And then he performs power
for me in his chair.
Now the LGBTQ community
and the human rights community in Russia,
many of their members
have adopted my pictures of Putin,
and they used them as a banner
to show everything that they believe
is wrong with power in their country.
I've been told recently
that anyone in Russia who is caught
circulating my pictures online
in connection with human rights violations
will be arrested
and they will go to jail immediately.
Whose eye is this?
Someone you love?
Someone you hate?
It belongs to a man who was prepared
to go to jail for his beliefs.
The late, great Muhammad Ali.
I said to him, "Muhammad,
you are the greatest.
Teach me to be great.
How can my generation be as great
as your generation had to be
during the civil rights era?"
He couldn't speak very well
because of Parkinson's.
So I had to get close, and he whispered,
"I have a confession to make."
"What is it?" I said.
He said, "I wasn't as great
as I said I was."
(Laughter)
"Holy shit," I said.
"That's the biggest confession
I ever heard in my life.
The whole world knows
you as Ali, the greatest."
And then he said,
"I think you misunderstand me.
I'll tell you what was great," he said.
"It wasn't me.
It was the people,
saw themselves in my struggle,
in my story."
And then he turned it to me,
And now I've got the great honor
to turn it to you.
And he said,
"If you can get people to see themselves
in the story that you put forward,
then you have a chance
of achieving greatness.
But that greatness is never
you personally.
That's something much bigger,
called bridge building."
A light bulb went off in my brain,
so I took this picture.
My last ever portrait of Muhammad Ali.
Not as a prizefighter or a champion,
but as a compassionate bridge builder,
thinking of the underdog.
Whose eye is this?
Someone you love, someone you hate?
A different type of underdog.
Belongs to this man.
So I said to him, "Donald,
"Let's be human with each other
just for a few minutes.
We've all followed your career," I said.
"No one can doubt, it's an extraordinary
career path you've had.
But there's always something about you.
There's always an air
of tension and controversy
about things you say and do in public.
And I'm sure that's
intentional on your part.
But it feels to me as if you're
in the middle of an emotional storm.
Personally, I couldn't live
with that anxiety all the time.
I want to know how you weather the storm."
He calmly looks at me and he says,
"I am the storm."
(Audience murmurs)
The eyes are always watching us.
But how do we use our eyes?
Do we look?
Or do we see?
When you look at this picture,
you might find yourself thinking
about the politics of war.
But when you see
the person in this picture,
you get to know Jessica.
Jessica holds a flag they draped
over her husband's coffin,
who had recently been killed
fighting in Iraq for America.
I took this picture in her home.
Now she has his wedding ring
around her neck on a chain.
When you're killed in combat,
the US military sends your clothes
and personal belongings
back to the family in a big box.
Jessica had recently received the box
but had not yet had
the courage to open it.
There it lay, closed, at the base
of her bed, in her bedroom.
I said to her, "Jessica, maybe
you should wear one of his army T-shirts
as a tribute to him in the picture."
She said, "I would.
But all his T-shirts are in the box.
Maybe now," she said,
"it's time for me to face that emotion."
So we both walked into her bedroom.
We both knelt at the base of her bed,
and we undid a latch each
of the box and lifted the lid.
And she burst into tears.
And I felt ashamed of myself.
For the first time in my life,
I had put a photograph
above the well-being of a person.
As I apologized, she said,
"You don't understand why I'm crying.
I'm crying," she said,
“because I just realized
they washed his clothes,
and I wanted to smell him again."
Did you feel that?
If you felt that ...
then something beautiful just happened.
We all came into this room
defined by our differences.
Men, women, old, young, Black, white.
Dare I say, members of the Left.
Dare I say, members of the Right.
Different genders,
different religious groups, cultures.
But we all felt that together.
What we felt is compassion.
Compassion for someone
you've never even met.
That's the power of human connection.
And that's why we will not go down
as the generation of connectivity
that disconnected itself, no.
I think we're going to rise up.
I think we're going to rekindle
the spirit of optimism.
It seems to me they underestimated
the resilience of humanity.
Whose eye is this?
Someone you love?
Someone you hate?
It belongs to a man who was robbed
of the power of human connection.
Professor Stephen Hawking.
Now, he was very ill
when I took this picture.
In fact, his whole body
had essentially shut down.
There was only one muscle
he could still work,
and that was underneath his eye.
His team of scientists placed a sensor
at the base of his glasses.
You can see it here.
And that sensor picks up
movement of that muscle.
And with that muscle,
he moves a cursor
over each letter of the alphabet
on his laptop screen.
He chooses a letter, builds a word,
constructs a paragraph,
and that's how he communicated
those epic statements about space,
time and humanity to us.
At the end of the session, I said to him,
"Professor, what an honor
it is for me to photograph you.
And I've seen how hard it is
for you to even communicate.
But I'm going to ask for a big favor."
I said, "I want one word
of wisdom from you.
One word from you,
it's going to be worth
a million words from anyone else."
We all waited.
His nurse was a little concerned.
I had heard that that muscle was failing,
and most of the things
he typed around this time
didn't mean anything.
Suddenly we heard, beep,
beep ... beep, beep, beep.
He was typing.
We all leaned in to the laptop screen
to see where the cursor is going to go,
and he went all the way to the letter W.
And he starts the next letter,
beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
All the way to the letter O.
And then the final letter.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
All the way back to the letter W.
Someone on the team said,
"W-O-W what does that stand for?
That's nonsense, it's a mistake."
And I said, "Hold on a minute.
That's not a mistake.
He just typed the word, ‘Wow.’
He just gave me a word my kids would use
about the beauty and majesty of life.
And isn't it amazing how the man
who faces so much adversity
still looks at the world
through the eyes of wonder?"
His nurse said, "He's exhausted.
Let's give his eyes a rest.
Let's take off his sensor,
take off his glasses and replace them
with his dark sunglasses."
And then I saw it.
A vision of a bad-ass rock star of hope.
And I took this picture.
This is my fitting tribute
to a legend of our time,
a man who believed that connection
equals compassion.
So I'm not going to leave you
with an answer.
I'm going to leave you with a question.
Are we to be bystanders,
like moths dancing
around somebody else’s flame?
Or are we to be upstanders,
and we light darkness ourselves
with our own torch of compassion?
Because when there is light,
we see each other not as strangers,
not as opponents
but as creative partners.
And then together,
we rebuild this troubled world.
Together, we reconnect.
Together, we earn the respect of history
and transform this chaos
into a beautiful cosmos.
Thank you for listening to me.
(Applause)